With a Bayesian detection rate and
base rate fallacy in mind,
let's discuss the system
architecture of network IDS.
First, typically the volume of packet
data in the network can be huge.
Which means the base rate at
the packet level is typically low.
For example, there can be tens of
millions of packets per day in
a network, but only a few involved
the intrusion activities.
Therefore, according to
the base rate fallacy,
if we apply detection
algorithms at the packet level,
this may result in very low
Bayesian detection rate.
Instead, we should apply
detection models to data
that has higher base rate.
This can be accomplished using
hierarchical architecture.
First, we can apply filters
to the packet data.
For example,
by inserting libpcap to capture
only packets to certain services.
Second, the event engine analyses
the filtered packet data, and
summarizes them into security related
events such as failed log in's.
Finally, detection models are applied
to the security related event data.
As we can see, the volume of data is
decreased first by a packet filter and
then the event engine.
Therefore, as long as we can keep
the intrusion evidence in the event data
the base rate is going to be a lot
higher than the original packet data.
As a result the IDS model
applied to the event data
will yield a higher
Bayesian detection rate.